هذا انا كنت تحدثت الى هذا الشاب اسمه عبد
الله وساتحدث اليه على على الهواء لاستمع
القصه لاني اوددت ان اسمعها منه على
الهواء وليس لشخصيا عبد الله كنا اتفقنا
اننا نحكي معك اولا انت من اين جئت من وين
جبت من سوريا مين الك هون مين بتستنى
كم عددهم اربع اشخاص
يعني انت مش ما حدا من اسرتك هون اصدقائك
اصحابك
كم عمرك انت 17 وهم من عمرك لا واحد من
عمره والباقي يعني اهله ثلاثه اهله وهو من
عمره يعني
الحمد لله هو حافظ لكتابه الكريم بس بتمنى
انه هيك يشوفوا يعني ماني خايف انه اذا
توفى بس بتمنى انه يشوفوا
ابدا من بالي بحيس هلا قدامي بس اتمنى
اشوف صوره وجهه لحتى هيك
يعني كان يتم يونسني
عندك احساس لانه اليوم اخرجوا شخص على قيد
الحياه من هون باذن الله راح يطلع حي باذن
الله لا تقنطوا من رحمه الله يعني انت جئت
هنا عبد الله تستنى صديقك يطلع طبعا
وعائلته ان شاء الله هو يكتب باذن الله
اذا الله قدر ان شاء الله بس يطلعوا بروحي
بفديه بس
ايش بدنا نسوي الله يحميك عبد الله ان شاء
الله يطلع حي وان شاء الله تشوفوا وتستمر
صداقتكم يعني طول السنين
تمنيته يصيروا عشره
هو مواليد اربعه ثلاثه
كان عم يستنى بس اللحظه يصير فيها عمره 17
سنه هيك لحتى يقلب بس يسال هيك انه على
طول وعن هيك وبس بدو انه بس يا حرام بس
للاسف ان شاء الله ان شاء الله يطلع على
قيد الحياه ان شاء الله ان شاء الله يطلع
على قيد الحياه احمد انا هذا مشهد يعني
مؤثر هذا الشاب ينتظر صديقه يعني لا يريد
سوى ان يراه